hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester these are the finals and
it's maxime beaugeois graph with the
white piece against magnus carlsen is
the third game of the blitz
a first game ended in a drop then the
second game was won by MDL and now
Magnus has to bounce back or if Maxime
for Sheila Graham in the blood section
then it's all over
since Hugh Magnus will be down four
points and you only get two points for a
win in the boot section so without
further ado let's check it out and let's
see what what poison will Magnus dig out
to to use and throw in via love you know
off of his game as now MVL has the white
pieces so efore sorry about that
bye Maxime we have c5 Magnus goes for
the Sicilian a knight to f3 d6 and d4 we
have seen at first Knight captures
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now Bishop
to d7
we have Bishop to g5 just continuing
development with east six and now Knight
d2 b5 with a double attack on the d6
pawn so here Magnus captures with the
bishop with the strip characters with
Czech and Knight to c6 Queen to f3
developing the Queen preparing to Castle
queenside and here Bishop to e7 and now
II five so this has all been played
before and here Knight to d5 is the mood
that's always being played but Magnus
goes for D captures on e5 and it is as I
move tended we have a completely new
game so this is that a little bit of
poison that Magnus decided to use we
have Bishop captures and c6 with check B
captures and the Queen captures on c6
again with check King f8 now and we have
castles but castles King side Quintus c8
Magnus offers a queen trade now where if
you trade you you can do this but it
will be somewhat difficult to develop
your night since the c2 point is hanging
and you kind of don't want to put your
rook on a on a passive score like c1 so
here maxime just goes back Queen to f3
and do not work the b8 putting pressure
on the b2 pawn rook a2 b1 defending and
now
h6 attacking the bishop Bishop captures
and now
recaptures so you can start expanding
with f with f5 and also you can bring
the rook over to the G file to be used
for attack rook F 2 d1
maxine brings the rook into the game and
now f5 expanding now grabbing a very
nice control of of the well of these
squares here and also you're opening up
at the diagonal for the bishop with
Queen to e3 attacking d5 pawn and Queen
to c7 just defending Knights to a for a
preparing B 3 and C 4 if possible also
offering the C to pawn a 40 for the e5
pawn as the King is still here so the
grabbing of the e5 pawn will come with
an attack on the HH look so King the g7
first b3 now and here cross and says
okay we'll just capture this C to pawn
here next week and maybe even capture on
a 2 he gives up the e5 pawn with check
Bishop to f6 now ending out Queen to g3
check King to h7 so the King is a bit
cut off from the G file but it's not a
problem since the rook is coming to g8
either way we have Queen to b3 offering
a queen trade but just a rook H the c8
now bringing the rook into the game and
now if you trade then a Magnus already
gets a rook on the 2nd rank will be very
dangerous as the a 2 point will be under
attack also this f2 point will be under
attack if the bishop can for example
comes to c5 or somewhere along this
diagonal it will be hard to defend
so Queen to d2 and now rook the c7
preparing Ruby TCH to double up on the C
file g3 eliminating any background
weaknesses and not Ruby c8 s plan with a
3 and now King to g6 just improving the
position of the King and here Maxime
trades with Queen captures rook captures
and the now before as you no longer have
any targets here on a2 we have rook 8
the c4 and not allowing rook and Knight
to c5 to cut off your looks so nice to
see 5 now the DF 2 point will come under
attack so nice - d3 will nicely defend
it with Bishop the d4 with a double
attack
but now Knights the d3 just defending
that f2 f2 pond and the now rook the a
to finally Magnus goes for the a3 pawn
rug beat the c1 offering a trade rook
captures rook captures and now rook
captures an a3 so here Carson is is up
upon we have Knight to f4 with check
King to f6 and now comes King to f1 mvl
starts bringing the King into the game
but rook a to cutting off the looking
from entering the game night Stewie to
attacking the bishop bishop just goes
back to b6 and here we have f4 which
prevents the black King from entering
the game but also it you no longer have
this f2 upon the perhaps shield you from
the roof but again it's very hard that
if we be used as the shields and both
the rook and Bishop are attacking it we
have looked the b2 now going after this
pawn rook the c4 defending it and now
kinked East 7 now cousin brings the King
into the game at the other way around
with h4 and King to d6 we have Knight to
c3 and now comes looked f2 width check
kink that he want and now rook to f3
attacking the g3 pawn Knight back to e 2
guarding the pawn but now King to d5
making the white rook move away from the
defense of the b4 pawn rook to see it
and now look back to b3 as we have sort
of principle of two weaknesses white
will not be able to defend both of them
came to d2 now comes King to e4 first
going after the g3 point is well Knight
the c3 with check now comes King to f3
and here mvl doesn't really have any any
good moves this point will fall then all
of these guys will fall this pawn will
fall so he played rook to h8 he he
wanted to grab some material along the
way but here Magnus just played Bishop
to b4 which comes with a double attack
and it was of course in this position
that maxime beaugeois resigned the game
whatever you do you either lose the rook
or after the rook moves you lose the
night so either way you can just resign
which MVL did so by winning this game
Magnus has equalized and they now go
into the fourth game of the blitz which
if they
if it ends in a draw then they go into
playoffs or whoever wins the fourth game
of the Blitz is goes to the finals and I
may have forgotten to mention this ding
won his match against LaVon Oregon as he
bought he won both of the rapid games
and then the first game of the blade
section was drawn which was enough for
him to win
not so ding is the first finalist now
he's waiting for his opponent either in
Vellore or magnus so now that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it we we haven't
over analysed anything since it's a
blitz game it would be would be
pointless since they're very low on time
so I do hope you enjoyed that as well I
would like to thank Prakash Secor Mario
and see us and Pollock slow-mo for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
most likely with another game from this
very nice event as we have to see who
will face thing in the finals so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day